Namo Tassa Bhagavato Harahato Sambha Sambho Tassa Namo Tassa Bhagavato Harahato Sambha Sambho Tassa Namo Tassa Bhagavato Harahato Sambha Sambho Tassa
homage to the Buddha, the blessed, noble and fully self-enlightened one.
So the question about metta, we practice metta at the end of the day, could you say something about when and in what circumstances we can and should cultivate karuna, mudita and upeka and how they fit in with vipassana practice overall?
One of the
problems that may occur with vipassana is an objectivity which turns into an indifference that's your problem there taking this stand within ourselves of the objective observer just watching things arise and pass away can become shall we say too passive and you can
you can move towards indifference, you know, with the usual phrase, oh, it's just karma, you know.
So, you know, if somebody falls down screaming with pain before you, you can stand completely calm and say, oh, it's all right, it's just a bit of karma.
It's like the heart's not drawn because it's found this little place where it's untouched, you know.
And it's often a case of being afraid to get engaged, frankly.
There can be fear there of,
actually getting engaged in suffering.
And we do that when we note something and we're actually pushing it away.
See, that's the case where we're callousing ourselves, where we're drawing a thick skin in between that which knows, that which feels, and what there is to be felt, because it doesn't want to go there, basically.
But it kids itself and says, well, I can see it as a process, I can see the anicca, I can see it's not me, not mine.
but it's not me not mine in that sense it's not quite the right me not mine it's still ours in a conventional sense it's our baggage for heaven's sake so you have to be slightly careful about that so that's the right understanding when we do it properly but you can see that in the Eightfold Path you start off with this right understanding which has three levels remember the level of
receiving information from a teacher from the books and etc making it our own intellectual knowledge by contemplating it by thinking about it so that intellectually we have a confidence in it because it's now become our thought and making it real through vipassana a direct experience so now that's the first step
Right samadhi, right understanding.
The next one is samasankapa, right attitude.
So it has to systemically drop from this understanding into the heart as an attitude.
Or else it remains too remote.
And that's why we do metta.
That's the purpose of metta.
Because then it draws it.
So what is wisdom in action?
It's compassion, isn't it?
It's love, compassion and joy.
That's wisdom in action.
That's what it manifests as.
Some form of love, compassion, sympathetic joy and all the other virtues.
As an attitude that is in the heart, you see.
And then it goes right speech.
So that's the next thing.
It comes out through what we say.
Right action and then right livelihood.
So you see it flows out into society.
And because it flows out into society that way doesn't mean it can't flow back this way.
So depending on your job and what qualities your job demands, it will come back up the other way into attitude and into wisdom.
So if you have a job which, say, demands a certain service, a quality of service, and virtually every job does, apart from trafficking in human beings and arms and all the nasty bits, but most jobs can be seen as a service.
It's a compassionate thing, it's a loving thing, and that feeds into your attitude, and that gives you that interconnectedness.
the more you see yourself as interconnected the less that is of this me you know on my own doing my own thing in my own time in my own way you know to hell with you lot so it works either way see so that's why you can start with love and it'll feed back into wisdom and feed out into into action so there's your three paths you see
path of insight, path of wisdom, path of love, and the path of action, three karmas.
The Hindus delineate that, I think, more clearly than do the Buddhist lineage.
They have these three karmas, you see.
But it's there within the Buddhist teaching, there's no problem with that.
but the Buddha is very much inclined to approach the situation from right understanding.
Whereas you can see a religion like Christianity approaches it more from love, approaches it from that point of view.
So, in terms of the question,
how does it fit in with vipassana practice that's how it fits in so in a sense every time you do a session of vipassana there ought to be a little one minute it doesn't take long one minute two minutes of just bringing it into an attitude so the exercise we did there the first bit takes about what 15 minutes when you do it long ways there's only a couple of minutes when you just flash through all the different categories you don't even have to do that you just give it to yourself and all beings you know
And remember, if you want to use it to calm yourself, if you're having, so to say, difficulty sleeping, that's one of the gifts of metta.
It helps to relax the mind.
It gives the heart a good feeling when you fall asleep.
But to do that, you must choose somebody whom you have no problems with.
If you choose somebody you have problems with, it is the mind itself.
And definitely somebody whom you love who's passed away or fallen ill or something.
Then it just brings grief and stuff.
So it's basically to yourself and somebody or to all beings.
Simple phrase.
And you don't make these complicated phrases because that wakes you up.
It's very simple.
I had a very interesting experience with that, you know.
There's an Israeli man turned up at Kandabodha.
And he said he hadn't slept in his life.
He hadn't slept in his life ever.
And I said, no, not since I was a child.
Mainly because of trauma, you know, the bombs and all that.
I said, you must sleep.
He said, no, what happens is I lose consciousness for just a moment and then I'm awake again.
And I questioned him about it and he said he never slept.
He went into this sort of momentary
black out and came out again he was doing vipassana so i said to him well i said the the antidote has gone to the buddha is his loving kindness so i gave him the instructions that i've just given you which is a classic instruction you see and he came back the next day and he said he'd slept for two hours very joyful very happy and by the end of the week he was oversleeping sent me a present from israel
So, that was powerful, wasn't it?
So, back to the question.
You know, like when and in what circumstances?
Well, in the discourse on loving-kindness, the Buddha says to do it all the time.
It's just a way of being in the world.
coming into a situation with that open-heartedness with that kindness and remember you can flavor your own meditation with that when you're looking inward you can flavor the way that you're looking with a certain kindness and that's very helpful if you're working with something which isn't particularly pleasant so in terms of when and where all the time that's what the Buddha says those who live like that you know
will achieve liberation so if you think about it you know we're made up of these composites we're made up of the mind in terms of thinking and that and the heart with its emotional life and the body with its actions so somehow it's got to all work together and
It's just looking upon our lives as that way of being interconnected which brings up the idea of service.
You're never doing anything just for yourself.
There's always some, even if you're only doing it for yourself, it's so that you can be healthy and wise to help other people.
Do you know what I mean?
It's like always trying to make that connection.
I mean the Buddha does say,
you do things for yourself and others both yourself and others but I think you can sort of twist things to make it so that everything you do is in some sort of relationship with the world so that's when you do it I mean consciously when do you do it consciously as a neural effort
Well, the morning, obviously, and before you, in the evening sometime, with the meditation.
That's the two times we're supposed to sort of practice.
The morning is setting ourselves in the right frame of mind for the day.
And the evening is really letting whatever we've accumulated during the day, just give it time to evaporate.
And then you end with loving-kindness, you know, and that sets you up for the evening really, the evening TV.
It's alright as long as it's football.
But of course there are specific times when the various things are called upon, like Karuna, compassion, mudita, sympathetic joy.
and these things of course in the literature have their obvious enemy and their very subtle enemy so the obvious enemy of love is hatred but it's more subtle energy enemy is attachment now so long as we've got a self there will be attachment there's no way we can get rid of attachment just because we think it shouldn't be there it'll be there it's just knowing its manifestations
You can always normally tell when you're acting from an attached point of view because you're very pleased that somebody's doing what you told them to do.
You're very irritated because they're not doing what you told them to do.
And you're very annoyed because, or you're very afraid because they're not doing what you told them to do.
You see what I mean?
There's always some negativity comes up, you know, which manifests the attachment.
Which doesn't mean to say that what you're telling them to do isn't the right thing for them to do.
Or you're advising them to do, you know.
See, when I started this teaching, I used to get quite irked, miffed, by the fact I'd give these instructions and people wouldn't do them.
I thought, what's the bloody point?
I'm the teacher.
I said, go slow.
They should go slow.
See?
And then I had a long talk with myself.
And I thought, what are you getting miffed for?
See?
So now, if people don't do what I ask them to do,
that's fine but I'm very happy when they do you can move yourself over you see so it's just a case of recognizing that attachment some form of attachment will be there with relationships and with things and it's just knowing that that causes us some form of discomfort and sometimes heavy pain really but it's just knowing it as
the product of self, you see.
And then, the way we deal with it is exactly what Vipassana is teaching us.
You know, we feel it, we let it go, we don't feed into it.
And then as it passes away, we feed into the opposite.
There's a case in the scriptures where there's three Arahats living together, the Anarudhas, as they're called.
Of course, they are fully liberated.
And the Buddha asks them, how is it they live so peacefully together, you see?
And Aniruddha says, well, I say to myself, what if I put aside what I want to do and do what the others want to do?
See?
Now that's the selfless way.
But it only works if everybody else is doing the same.
Because if you say that and they're not saying it, you just get abused.
See?
So you have to be very careful about that one.
But at least you can have that attitude of at least first opening up to what the other wants.
When anybody, for instance, came to the Buddha and said, you know, what do you teach about karma?
What do you teach about this and that?
He would always reply, well, what's your understanding?
He never sort of launched into his, you know, well, this is it and this is the way it should be, you know.
So what's your understanding?
And then when they'd given them his understanding, he would argue with them
to show that their understanding had a flaw in it see and then when they saw the flaw they immediately dropped probably their conceited position of I'm right and the Buddha and this guy's wrong and because they were that open then he he told them what his teaching was not everybody accepted it even so you know now that's interesting because when they asked the Buddha how do you feel when somebody doesn't receive your teaching he says well it's all right
it's all calm but how do you feel when they do they feel joyful he knows his limits you can't enlighten somebody can you when we say that let me enlighten you let me disabuse you of your
When it comes to Karuna, the opposite, the obvious opposite is cruelty, of course.
Instead of wishing somebody's free of harm, you give them some.
Give them some pain.
The subtle one is pity, grief.
Feeling sorry for somebody.
Now, if you think about that, it sounds right to feel sorry, but you're not, you see.
there's an I in there feeling sorry for somebody there's a difference between that and empathy isn't there because with empathy you connect with that feeling because you've had similar feelings and that draws you to want to help but to say oh you poor thing you want to hit him don't you I'm so sorry for you thank you very much
so it's a subtle one because people think they're being kind by saying you know I feel so sorry for you mudita is joy the obvious enemy the obvious enemy of that is envy obviously envy and jealousy so by developing mudita we undermine those two
qualities, you know.
But the subtle one is excitement, interestingly enough.
Just getting excited, getting overexcited, sort of moving into an indulgence with it.
And what keeps it from doing that is this upeka.
What stops all these things from sort of going off is upeka, just that basis of an equanimous mind, the equanimity.
And the equanimity is, remember, always begins with that position of openness.
So you're not coming from a position.
So when the heart resonates with somebody else's happiness, it's at the level of their resonance.
You're not overdoing it, you know.
Which we often do because often underneath it we're pushing away the jealousy and the envy.
Oh, I'm so happy for you.
Oh, absolutely wonderful.
I remember once there was this monk, you know, it was just so painful.
And we were opening a centre and he said these lovely things, you see, about the centre and all these people who'd been involved and etc.
And then during lunch, you know, such a telltale, he said, he turned down and he said, you know, I meant every word I said.
That's a giveaway, isn't it?
You have to tell people that you meant every word you said.
Anyway, I prayed for him.
It's funny, isn't it?
Now, you see, this is something that doesn't really come up in Buddhist psychology.
Buddhist psychology, the way it comes from the Buddha...
I mean it's there in the sense of the anusaya, the potential defilements that sit underneath but I haven't really come across the Western idea of unconscious motivation which is actually affecting what you do and you don't really know it
people know it because it's in the inflection of your voice it's in the way that you hold yourself and what you are trying to make sincere and what you might actually believe as sincere other people actually perceive as completely insincere do you know what I mean?
and of course vipassana one of the things about vipassana is that you might be sitting here and if you do really note you'll catch these underlying thoughts because they'll come up you see
All the ones that we don't like to describe ourselves by, that don't fit in with our self-esteem.
The obvious one is envy and jealousy.
Envy is just about allowable, but jealousy is the way I would distinguish the two.
Maybe it's just my distinction, but envy is basically just wanting what the other person has.
And jealousy is the same, except you hate them for it.
You hate them for having what they have, you know.
and you know that that's basically saying to ourselves I'm inferior so we don't like to acknowledge that we're really envious or really jealous you know and so these things we you know and we hide from ourselves those things that don't fit into our idea of who we are our self-esteem and vipassana often you know gives us these little ins to ourselves which you know which
can be humiliating but at least now we know why nobody likes us you know before we didn't understand why people get upset with us you know people who say they're never angry and they're fuming that sort of silliness you know so opening up
the vipassana opens us up to ourselves and then we have to translate that so in terms of when and in what circumstance I mean there are obvious places where these they're called illimitables manifest but generally speaking what we're trying to develop is a concurrent attitude that runs with the wisdom we have that's all it runs concurrent so in the morning when
you know, when I say do these resolutions for the day, try and add.
See, I've got four of them now.
I keep building up.
It's getting ridiculous.
But you make a resolution on the wisdom side, a resolution on the attitude, a resolution about your work, a resolution.
See what I mean?
And just by doing that sincerely, eventually it turns.
It actually does work.
Things can creep up on you.
you see, I'll give you an example, I was, you know, when you go to the east as a monk, especially as a Suddhuhamdurua, as they call you in Sri Lanka, a white monk, you get this generally special treatment, because people are, people have a, their faith is raised that somebody of another culture should become a Buddhist, you know, it's not so
Strange now, but in the old days it would have been amazing, you know.
And you get there and people give you food and they ask you what you need and you get the medicine you want, the clothes you want, the shelter and everything, you know.
So I'd been, I'd gone back to Sri Lanka on one occasion and I was staying at this monastery in Colombo and they were serving this food and over a period of two or three days I was getting really irritated.
I thought, why not?
Then I'm a Westerner, why don't they offer me an egg?
See, they don't like... Sri Lankans don't offer eggs to monks because it's part of meat.
And the order's meant to be vegetarian.
Just as an aside, when I first joined this order in Khandaboda, one of the monks said very, you know, very proudly to me that, you know, we're vegetarians, you see.
And on the same meal, all this fish was served, you know, and...
A westerner made a wry comment that fish were automated self-propelling vegetables.
Sort of allowable.
And to my surprise, I was feeling really disgusted with this food, which not so long ago I was really delighting in.
I thought, this is really strange, you see.
And then I just caught this complete lack of ingratitude for the food that was being given me.
And I was moaning that they weren't giving me, you know, spaghetti and toast.
And as I saw that and I came back and I thought, you know, I thought, for heaven's sake.
So I began to develop gratitude.
And of course the food started to taste beautiful again.
It just shows how your attitude, you know, really cancels your relationship to things, you know.
So just to bring it all together the reason why the Buddha practices metta is because that's your basic attitude to all living beings and once that's set properly the other two illimitables mudita, this joy and compassion arise naturally you don't have to worry about it I know that in Buddhist history
the Mahayana took compassion as their big thing which is understandable because the Buddha is talking about suffering and the end of suffering you know but that was generally a reaction against what was a tradition that had become too vipassana bound, too head bound really and somehow was losing contact with the people it seems you get this movement according to the and then it goes right the other way there's some school that thinks that Karuna is more important than wisdom
It's completed a circle, you see.
Any questions come up about that?
Well, I'm only suggesting that.
It can be any resolution.
Whatever the day is.
Like, for instance, if you know you've got a hard day at work coming up, you resolve to endure patiently.
You know, if you know it's going to be a day off, you make a resolution to use it to the best advantage rather than just fritter the time away.
Anything, anything really.
But there may be certain resolutions which are very continuous because you're working with something.
I mean, to make a resolution to develop moment-to-moment mindfulness is a sort of basic attitude, you know.
And sometimes I find it comes up during the day, quite spontaneously.
Could you explain what is meant when one reads about applied or sustained thoughts and where they appear in the jhanas?
Also, how do they differ in quality?
I assume that they are skillful application of thought.
Can you explain in what way
and what's to look out for in case of slipping into a skilful application.
These are technical terms, vittaka, vichara, and in a sense they are slightly mistranslated by thought.
It's more that the thinking mind is directed to an object, it's not thinking about something.
so talking about it in terms of vipassana when you note something like for instance you're noting the breath so rising falling and then if you have a touching point let's just say make it easy rising falling so rising falling you can see that the intellect is involved but in a sense it's not actually drawn into the object as it were
And that's why, because the effort, the focus isn't there, it flits away.
But you keep bringing it back.
Keep bringing it back.
You see?
And that's the process of vitaka.
The image that they give in the commentaries is a bee flying around a flower.
A bee flying around a flower.
As you keep doing that, as you're rising, falling, there's a feeling of sort of being drawn into it and getting stuck on the object, as it were.
It feels like you can't even move off it sometimes, that sort of feeling.
That's when the bees landed on the flower, you see.
That's the vichara.
And it's a sign to the meditator that their focus, their concentration is now matured, right?
And as you know, you've got to do this every sitting.
It's not as though it's matured and that's the end of that, you know, like cheese.
It's like, yeah, you've got to keep working at it.
So then it becomes this vichara, you see, vittica vichara.
if you were doing metta practice, you would just do your good wishes, may all beings be happy, you see, but the mind would be moving all over the place, but as you keep doing it, it's as though the phrase now comes naturally, and you're stuck with it, and it's there in the background, and it's easy to stay with that phrase, so at that point it's become vichara, vittaka vichara, and they are
When that's really nicely developed, the mind's very still, you're probably in what's known as the first jhāna.
That's the sign of the first jhāna.
And there are two types of jhānas which I have writ about on the website.
There's one called Lākana jhāna and there's one called Alambana jhāna.
I'm giving you now the commentarial stuff.
I'm sounding very learned, but this is about the limit of it.
The Lakanajana are those concentration states which are developed on the three characteristics of impermanence, unsatisfaction in our self, and therefore they belong to the Vipassana tradition.
The Alambanajana are those that are developed on an object, such as loving kindness or the breath,
which are to do with the jhāna so what that's saying is that the level of concentration is the same but with the jhāna there's no investigation there's just the development of that mental state and the enjoyment of it and the Buddha said that's good because it's developing the heart with the vipassanā there's always the intelligence there's always the investigation
that's the difference and that's why anybody practicing jhana can even unwittingly slip into vipassana and those in vipassana can unwittingly slip into jhana they just move between the other but certain traditions will go down one of those paths there will be a combination of jhana vipassana or just vipassana
the Mahasi was the pathana the dry way as it's called pathana only so that's the meaning of this vittaka vichara yeah applied and sustained it's just a funny translation it's difficult to translate these things sometimes yeah any questions any Bhante could you say more about the meaning of Satipaññā
also I've heard the term Sati Samparjanya which sounds similar but I don't know the origin significance of it now Satipanya is not scriptural you'll not find anywhere in the scriptures the two words Satipanya stuck together like that and I pinched it from the great teacher Buddha Dasa who taught because he used to talk about it at least that's what I remember and what they are are the two qualities of the of the Buddha mind of the of the
enlightened person now although we talk about them being two things actually they're one and the same thing one is its passive quality and the other one is active so first of all to understand something you've got to look and when you look then you see or you don't see see so the first is receiving you see that's why I try to emphasize this quiet abiding of just being open
of the equanimity of just receiving you see that's your sati and in receiving once in receiving one sees one one one understands yeah there's a difference between opening up and and letting things come to you as opposed to looking for something
because when you're looking for something you're coming from a position you're coming from a past experience, a conceptual idea now that's going to corrupt the paññā and we can say in general, spiritually speaking when you're looking for something because you're coming from some idea, some notion
if you get what it is that you've been looking for well if you don't get it you're disappointed and you're frustrated and if you do you you're deluded you know you go around thinking you are enlightened because you because it fits in with your concepts of what nibbana is then that's it you've had it you're in the state of perdition there's little hope at least in this lifestyle
they say how do they put it now the illness caused by the intellect by conceited intellect is like the illness caused by a medicine if you've got a medicine to cure an illness that's good but if the medicine itself gives you an illness then you're really stuck so
the idea of sati is this complete openness and that's what the Buddha called his discourse on this whole vipassana thing satipatthana the establishment of sati yeah and if you go through the opening stanzas of that you get good translations now Bhikkhu Bodhi and places like that you'll see he goes through the stages of just first of all just getting in touch with the breath you know it's a long breath a short breath he's just getting in touch with the breath
and then as you get in touch with the breath you calm the body you calm the mind see that's the sati you're just pulling back from it just letting it calm itself you see through the breath and then you begin to note the impermanence of it or the process of it the beginning and the end and the middle bits and then he says when
just when there's just enough sati just enough paññā insight will arise and you can't make that happen you just you slowly develop it through this attitude of placing your attention on the object with that openness and with the presumption with the faith that there is this intelligence within that looking you see now
the three things that always come together, the three words that always come together is ātāpī-sampajāno-sātimā so the ātāpī is the effort and it's continuous unremitting effort it's actually a word which is somehow related to mortification exercises but it's meant to be that sort of continuous unrelenting gentle effort to remain mindful
the sampajāṇya is with this intelligence, with this intuitive intelligence, not the intellect, not thinking and being aware, it's an adjective so that sampajāṇya-sati-mā, the nouns that come from that are sati-pāṇya and just as a little aside what happened was in 98 when I returned from Sri Lanka
and during that year decided I was going to stay in Britain I wasn't going to go back and I realized that to stay here meant that I'd have to teach because the support there wasn't the internal structure for easy support for a monk you know you have to have to teach really
I asked a friend well somebody said to me well you need to set something up so they set a website up for me it said you need a logo so I asked this fellow who's a printer who worked a little bit in those early in 98 it's funny how things have moved so fast to make up a logo and I gave him some ideas you see I said well I said I wanted to be a dhamma chakra a wheel you know and I wanted to have
12 spokes for the 12 links of the dependent origination, cut into four for the Four Noble Truths, eight for the eight paths.
And it had all these, 16 of them, 10 of those, had everything on this wheel, you see.
Well, the poor man struggled at it.
And when it came out, it was horrible.
And I didn't know what to say.
We must have spent hours on this thing.
And I felt really terrible.
I thanked him, of course.
and quietly put it to the side, you know.
He wasn't a sort of person to hold grudges.
And what it did was, it made me stop and think, well, what am I teaching?
That's what it made me do, which is rather good, actually.
I said, what is it I'm teaching?
And these words came quite spontaneously at the time.
I'm teaching Satipaña.
And that's how I ended up with this logo I've got.
and the five whiskers the actual circle the circle without the whiskers if you can imagine it's just one circle with all those petals you often get that symbol especially in Burma and they're the 24 patches that we chant 24 relations and I stuck these whiskers in to for the five spiritual faculties going inward and coming out
They were supposed to be the four illimitables with wisdom pushing them out, you see.
And the inner circle, which is free of color, where the things stop, that was meant to be a symbol for Nibbana in this life, for the Buddha as he was living.
And the black spot is Parinibbana, total Nibbana.
That was the idea of it.
All this you will find written up on my website.
In great detail.
So, that's the Satipanya, anyway, that's what it means.
And as I say, I filched it off.
A very good teacher, Buddha Datha, whom I really was following yesterday when I was talking about this business of rebirth.
if you look at the text carefully enough the Buddha is talking about rebirth of self it's all about the rebirth of self and the suffering of rebirth of self and there's a phrase which is not quoted so often actually but it should be and it's in the it's a consciousness in the Pali it's it's about
That's one of the five quotes that I know.
I don't want you to think, oh, this fellow knows Pali.
I've learned this one especially off by heart so I can keep quoting it.
And it's a consciousness, see, he used the word consciousness.
It's the same word that he uses for the five candles, for the five aggregates.
So one is vijnana, you see.
But there it has a different meaning.
There it's an act of cognition, right?
but then he says there is this consciousness which is not touched by any of the senses so you can't see it you can't smell it or anything else you can't think about it you can't emote there's nothing there at all and he says it's boundaryless because there's no phenomena it's only phenomena that makes a boundary isn't it it's only the walls of this room that give the room a boundary if there's no phenomena it's boundaryless
And in all directions full of light.
And as far as I know, that only comes up once in the scriptures.
And it comes up as an answer to a question.
And the question is, where is it that the four great elements come to an end?
Now the four great elements, remember, are fire, earth, water and air, right?
So what the question is really saying, where does the world come to an end?
And he says, that's the wrong question, he says, where does the world not find a footing?
And then he makes this statement.
Now, the whole of Mahayana is basically based on that statement.
Because in early Buddhism, the Buddha is much more, the Buddha likes to put the axioms on the experience of Nibbana.
In later Buddhism, the question was asked, well, what is it that experiences Nibbana?
And that's where the thing shifts towards consciousness and the study of consciousness as such.
Some very good histories on that, by the way, if you want to read about it.
The evolution of Buddhist thinking and practice.
And that's where you get the evolution of the practice of Zen and Dzogchen, you see.
just the awareness.
So when you trace that back to the original scriptures, whether it's the Theravada scriptures or the Sarvastavadin scriptures, you always come across this accent on sati.
You know, if you were to put the whole of the Buddha's teaching in a practical teaching anyway, in one word, it would have to be sati.
I can't think of another word that would fit so closely to what he's trying to teach.
What is sati?
How do you develop it?
Where does it lead to when you develop sati?
That's it.
So you can see why I cling to the words satipanya.
You can see why I'm very attached.
So I think that brings us to the end of our questions in terms of what's written there, I think.